[Musica]
fin da piccola Sono sempre stata una
bambina molto energica la figlia
iperattiva che fa impazzire i genitori
riuscivano a tenermi calma e tranquilla
solo con i videogiochi
questo mi ha fatto sentire un po' una
pecora nera nel corso degli anni però
per trasformare questa mia etichetta in
un'opportunità ho deciso di darmi un
nickname un nome d'arte da
videogiocatrice che in giapponese
significa Giglio nero kuro Lily
voi vi chiederete Per quale motivo una
video giocatrice qui che ci parla di
utilità sociale
Sono una millennial sono cresciuta tra
quello che c'era prima e l'arrivo dei
telefonini di internet degli smartphone
I videogiochi sono sempre stati per me
un modo per socializzare che fosse
andare da casa di mio cugino per
guardarlo giocare ho ancora da marco il
mio vicino di casa era molto più grande
di me aveva diverse console che io non
avevo un PC potentissimo ed era felice
di farmi da mentore perché condividevamo
insieme questa grande passione per i
videogiochi passione che poi ho
trasmesso anche ad alcuni dei miei
fratelli dato che sono la più grande di
Sei fratelli
i videogiochi per me hanno sempre
significato un modo per per legare un
legame con con le altre persone e per me
questo lavoro È qualcosa di veramente
importante lo prendo molto sul serio
Diciamo che un giorno i genitori di
Marco decidono di andarsene decidono di
trasferirsi e io mi trovo senza il
migliore amico che fino a quel momento
aveva condiviso con me questa grande
passione ci perdiamo totalmente di vista
per poi un giorno rincontrarci per caso
ad una fiera ovviamente ci riconosciamo
subito nonostante fossero passati 20
anni dal nostro ultimo incontro lui mi
fa i complimenti per il mio lavoro sui
social e io scopro che lui ha aperto una
sala Land a Rimini un locale in cui le
persone possono giocare ai videogiochi
dalle postazioni PC o Console e
consumare alimenti o bevande
quell'incontro mi ha fatto molto
riflettere mi ha fatto pensare da dove
Entrambi siamo partiti e da dove nascono
tutte queste nuove professioni
Facciamo un passo indietro
vi siete mai chiesti Da quale esigenza
nascono i social media e i social
network
Pensiamo ad esempio al famosissimo
Facebook è nato per caso ma da
un'esigenza ben precisa aggregativa
quella di riunire le persone di
riallacciare rapporti perduti nel tempo
e di conoscere nuove persone fare nuove
amicizie quindi un'esigenza da animali
sociali
questo perché Aristotele già nel IV
secolo avanti Cristo diceva che l'essere
umano è un animale sociale e che
costruisce la propria identità e il
proprio comportamento grazie al rapporto
che ha con l'altro e alla appartenenza
ad un gruppo
quindi possiamo dire che questa esigenza
di interazione che abbiamo tra di noi è
qualcosa di atavico che ha trovato
spazio e preso forma anche in queste
nuove piattaforme
e dopo i social network arrivano i
social media
piattaforme nelle quali le persone
possono mettersi davanti a una
videocamera e condividere qualcosa con
persone che li guardano e possono
commentare in diretta
ad esempio viene in mente Twitch una un
servizio di live streaming dove io mi
trovo da tantissimo tempo dove ho
iniziato la mia carriera Il mio hobby
che poi è diventato un lavoro Beh
sappiate che Twitch questa sorta di
televisione in diretta dove le persone
possono commentare
ha registrato 140 milioni di utenti
attivi nel 2022 con 30 milioni di
persone che ogni giorno guardano una
diretta streaming gestita da 9,2 milioni
di Streamer come me
Beh sembrano numeroni se poi pensiamo
che nel 2020 nel primo trimestre del
2020 Twitch ha registrato 3,1 miliardi
di ore Guardate mentre nel 2021 nel 2021
scusate c'è un cellulare nella slide ma
io me lo ricordo bene 2021 Ha registrato
6,3 miliardi di ore Guardate quindi dal
2020 al 2021 abbiamo raddoppiato i
numeri
Questo è un fenomeno più sociologico che
Social un fenomeno che va osservato va
abbracciato per il quale mi piace
parlare di utilità sociale
e Voi direte i social sono qualcosa che
viene considerato alienante viene
considerato qualcosa come un distacco
dalla realtà
Beh il motivo per cui molte persone ogni
giorno guardare una diretta streaming
nella mia mente è logico ci possono
essere tante risposte a questa domanda
ma a me viene in mente subito una parola
interazione in fisica questo concetto è
spiegato con due particelle anche di
diversa natura che agiscono l'una
sull'altra modificando il proprio stato
e la propria energia
un giorno mi trovavo a questa fiera a
Bologna è accaduto un anno fa stavo
chiacchierando con alcuni ragazzi ad uno
stand ragazzi della mia community molti
dei quali sono qua in mezzo e si
avvicina a questa ragazza che
Timidamente mi dice Ciao Sara io ti
seguo da moltissimo tempo e poi mi
abbraccia e con voce tremante aggiunge e
settimana prossima Ve l'ho ricoverata in
una clinica per disturbi alimentari e
sappi che sei tu che mi hai dato il
coraggio di fare questo passo perché so
che ogni pomeriggio tu sarai lì con me
so che le tue dirette mi terranno
compagnia quindi non mi sento sola
questo come tanti altri episodi che
portano il cuore e in abbracci pieni di
gratitudine non racconta storie di
videogiochi ma di persone di umanità in
connessione
ovvio
come TV e giornali amano spesso
ricordarci è facile cadere preda della
dipendenza dai Social E dai videogiochi
perché fondamentalmente sono cose che ci
piacciono ci fanno stare bene quindi ne
vorremmo sempre di più
Il punto è che quando utilizziamo un
computer o una console o qualsiasi
dispositivo digitale
produciamo nel nostro cervello dopamina
un neurotrasmettitore che regola il
sistema di ricompensa del nostro
cervello in più arriva la serotonina che
regola l'umore e l'ossitocina collegata
alla famiglia collegata alla
socializzazione all'affettività questo
crea un cocktail potenzialmente
esplosivo ci fa avere quasi una
assuefazione perché è facile cercare la
gratificazione immediata nell'utilizzo
della tecnologia Dobbiamo però ricordare
che la dipendenza da internet non è
solamente un cocktail di ormoni ma a
causa da ricercare anche nella
Sociologia nella psicologia
Quindi come possiamo
resistere a tutto questo Beh diciamo che
dovremmo fin da subito
insegnare a noi stessi e ai bambini fin
da piccoli una sorta di equilibrio con
la vita di tutti i giorni e l'utilizzo
di social e videogiochi una sorta di
Social Life Balance
io stessa ho tre consigli che metto in
pratica che vorrei dare a voi uno
Cerca di non paragonarti mai agli altri
non paragonarti mai alle persone che
vedi sui social media sui social network
perché quello che vedi è solo la parte
di una vita di queste persone a volte
non rappresenta necessariamente neanche
la verità a volte è qualcosa di fittizio
di costruito altre volte Appunto È solo
una piccola parte di esse non vedi tutto
il resto quindi mettersi a paragone Non
è mai positivo 2 mantieni un equilibrio
online offline Cerca di fare cose che ti
portano lontano anche dal mondo della
tecnologia ogni tanto come fare una
passeggiata chiacchierare con un amico
uscire all'aria aperta leggere un libro
fare sport
Su quello non sono molto brava però il
resto lo faccio
cerca di limitare i contenuti tossici
attorno a te cerca di non seguire
persone che promuovono contenuti
negativi che vanno in qualche modo ad
impattare con la tua vita di tutti i
giorni a darti un sentimento di
negatività ogni tanto una pulizia
contatti non fa male
oggi su questo palco ho portato me
stessa una video giocatrice che ha
realizzato il suo sogno di bambina e la
trasformata in un lavoro che prende
molto sul serio
dovete sapere che Walt Disney diceva che
tra un sogno è un obiettivo c'è una data
e per me quella data è oggi aprile 2023
10 anni come creatrice di contenuti
digitali 10 come il tema del Tex che è
la Unione di due numeri l'uno e lo zero
l'uno che rappresenta il pieno e lo zero
che rappresenta il vuoto
un numero che per me è stato un insieme
una fine e un inizio
e se oggi sono qui a parlarvi di utilità
sociale una video giocatrice che tanti
anni fa era considerato una nerd
e è perché ci credo È perché vedo tante
persone che sono qui che mi hanno
trasmesso un sacco di calore io avevo
paura di salire su questo palco ieri era
totalmente vuoto qui era vuoto e io
avevo paura ma poi li ho visti mi hanno
trasmesso un sacco di energia di calore
e per me questi ossigeno ed è l'ossigeno
che sono riuscita a costruire in questa
Confort zone anche tramite i social
perché spesso Questi ragazzi sono timidi
a volte insicuri non riescono facilmente
a fare amicizia in altri modi mentre
tramite queste comfort zone che noi
creiamo per loro si sentono a loro agio
non giudicati magari si conoscono così
tramite una chat però poi vengono agli
eventi vengono alle fiere C'è chi ha
trovato il fidanzato La Fidanzata Chi
esce il sabato per una pizza ed è bello
sapere di aver creato questo luogo
sicuro per loro
per poi trasformare queste amicizie
digitali in qualcosa di reale
e torno a dire che se sono qui oggi e
perché credo nell'utilità sociale del
mio lavoro perché sono una Gamer che
prende molto sul serio il divertimento
perché come diceva Italo Calvino il
divertimento È una cosa seria
Grazie